who would you say have been your uh
mentors or influences in the indigenous
community
oh gosh mostly people you've never heard
of people that you have heard of
i would definitely say when no no duke
continues to be one of my heroes and she
has been from
you know many many many many years um
but in my own personal life certainly um
the only other the only other indigenous
person in the town where i grew up um
remain in massachusetts is where i
actually grew up it was i was adopted
away from my community and there was one
other indigenous person in the town his
name was leonard bayer and he was a
musician and he was the mailman and he
was narragansett indian
and uh uh then um
in my late teens i was re-adopted or
adopted for real
into my cree family who may or may not
be relatives but amel and clara star
blanket piper and jb cashewarm
and the just uh
solomon rat who continues to run a
wonderful website called cree literacy
dot org
he's been translating a lot of my
indigenous themed songs like my country
tiz is like people you're dying into
cree so if anybody's interested in that
i mean there are a lot of things going
on uh and being done by people you've
never heard of and to me that's very
good news because you probably have
people in your life like that too
for sure that's also part of what this
is all about right is to shine the
spotlight on people who haven't had it
who deserve to have it right
yeah yeah yeah and some and a lot you
know but a lot of the people who are
doing the real work um in um
just having to do with indigenous issues
of any kind are are not they're not
professionals
they didn't go out and get a law degree
although that's a very good thing to
have uh there are a lot of people who
don't have a degree of any kind and
they're really doing the um the
necessary work but you know the real the
most important work is right here
the dalai lama said that you carry the
the most important tool of peace with
you all the time and that's your smile
you know and the attitude that will
bring on a smile and just working
together person to person
is uh it's another part of the solution
you have people over here in offices
making lists and coming up with think
tanks and solutions and then you have
other people who don't do any of that
and they're just as important you know
in order to have a sphere you need all
parts so
let's keep going you know
absolutely well let's talk specifically
about the entertainment industry right
um what do you think are some of the
ways that we can
i i work towards that being more
inclusive because we do see a lot of
artists coming up a little bit but you
know creating more spaces for them well
a lot of the entertainment industry like
any industry or business it's about the
business it's not really about the
entertainment so one of the things that
i think would really help would be if
the entertainment industry would start
really coming forward to the public
because they're the ones who buy the
stuff
that the business people are trying to
sell and that the artistic people are
loving to make see it's it's three
things is those artists is the business
people who they don't have to be able to
carry a tune or draw a straight line and
then it's the public and i think that
the industry would help us a little bit
more in letting the public know that oh
there's a huge white industry music
industry hundreds of thousands of people
working together to make sure that this
music is developed and heard presented
properly you know so that you get to
hear it the black music industry is huge
the latino music industry we don't have
one so consequently we don't have the
networking opportunities we don't have
the address book we don't know who to
call we don't know who would help
and so we're kind of starting from
scratch and i think if the public
realized that uh there's an awful lot of
good music that they are not hearing
because these are the days when you can
go online and you can find it and there
are a lot of great indigenous playlists
out there i've made a few myself
well so what's been your experience
because you know you're talking about
the the fact that yeah there's a little
bit of a um
not really recognition of the indigenous
music industry as opposed to other
industries that exist um
what's been your experience like growing
up and especially where before the the
digital age um
get being in this industry that has been
a little bit less diverse than it should
be and that's you know
[Laughter]
you are diplomatic
um
well it's been real hard i mean
it's been real hard to me
when i was growing up there weren't any
role models out there except for maybe
harry smith
uh from six nations uh also known as jay
hill rece j silverheels who created and
played the role of tonto on radio
television movies um and he was a friend
of mine eventually but when i was
growing up he was about the only
indigenous person that i would hear
about things are better now now that now
especially in canada but not so much in
the us you can pick up the newspaper and
read about indigenous people doing all
kinds of things everything you think of
um but we're absent in most of the rest
of the world we are just plain not there
uh just like we don't have a music
industry it's not it's not as though
anybody's trying to keep us out is
nobody's helping us to get in the junos
have done
they have they've done
about they've done some things you know
that are really significant but still
we're not where we need to be and the
you know i used to think that you know
i'd look back on my growing up listening
mostly to whatever was on the road you
know frank sinatra and tony bennett and
other um
singers of the time and then when black
music all of a sudden you can hear it on
the radio oh wow the combination was i
thought really exciting and when we
first established the music of
aboriginal canada category the journals
you know years ago um
i i just envisioned that
indigenous music along with everybody
else's music presented in the right way
could be a thing that people would enjoy
and we sure enjoy making the music so um
things are better now and are going to
continue to get better i think there are
lots of indigenous musicians out there
but it was very hard
and when i say there were no role models
i'm not kidding there certainly weren't
any in in music and i remember in the
60s i was invited to take a part in
television's first two-hour music for
television series called the virginian
and i said i would only take the part if
all of the indigenous
roles were played by indigenous people
and of course they said oh no that's
that's you know you're asking too much
and besides we have makeup artists and
we have they can turn a dog into a cat
and we have uh filipinos and italians
and jewish people we've got all kinds of
people who can play those roles but what
i said was the same thing is what i'll
say to you today
it's about more than just fooling white
people so that you can make a buck
it's about more than that we are real
we're your neighbors we're your friends
we're your relatives and we have
something to contribute that you don't
even know what you're missing
a lot of people are watching reservation
dogs that's good you know so there are
there is like um it gives you a hint
about the car the cross current of uh
indigenous talent that's there and it's
starting to develop and now at least you
can see you can see that one and
hopefully what it's going to do is make
you curious enough to poke around on the
internet and find us all because we are
here
and so i think you may have kind of
answered my next question on that a
little bit but you know what advice
would you give i think to non-indigenous
people who want to be allies
you know i'm on the board of the donny
wenjack fund and uh there are some
really good um
thinkers
on that board um along with me and uh
one to answer your question uh bob watts
who's a really incredible um mohawk
thinker from six nations is also on the
board and he had a he had a nice a nice
way of um
of uh putting it
uh
you know he said get beyond nice words
you know when you when you're talking to
people who don't know get beyond nice
words
understanding that the system the system
not you but the system is rotten it's
like an old bridge it's it needs it
needs to be fixed replaced repaired
understanding that the system is rotten
doesn't mean you are rotten
just that you've been blind and
profiting from the wrong outcomes and i
would agree with bob you know it's very
very hard especially for indigenous
people and indigenous kids to face this
horror history that's not news to most
indigenous adults but it is news to a
lot of non-indigenous adults who didn't
happen to read the newspapers when the
stories came out as long ago as in 1920.
we've known about it for a long time
it's just that certain people want to
keep on making a buck so that you won't
apply funding to where it's needed in
this case in other words away from
whoever happens to be the greedy guy of
the moment you know
bad leadership is not new neither is
good leadership you know kind of comes
and goes and waves um there is something
i would like to say also since we're
taught since we're mentioning the
residential schools and since i
mentioned donnie wenjack i want to read
you five things um uh
you know the 94 um um
uh activities that people can um it's
the calls to action i think right thank
you that's what i'm trying to say the 94
calls to action are very very important
and this is what we've this is what we'd
like people to know about too this is
how you can help deny the narrative that
this was some isolated incident
no
channel your feelings of anger toward
action
uncover undocumented graves across
canada's residential schools
get it done
reunite families with the remains of
their loved ones
it's sad
accept the truth of residential school
survivors and indigenous people's lived
experiences
and
you know
just that even if you do just that i
think it'll increase your sensitivity i
think it'll affect your life
i think that'll affect the people that
you deal with in your life from now on
bad things happen
so do good things and you know it's up
to us to paddle on the side of the canoe
you know we have we get to steer this
boat you know and me and everybody else
so
thanks for being here
you